hey David when is and isn't it okay for
administration's to meet with political
adversaries it seems like a round Trump
doing it there are a lot of just
hypocritical double standards for
political partisanship sake
excellent question this the question of
when should we meet with an adversary
and when shouldn't we who should we
negotiate with and who shouldn't we
negotiate with there is no set list of
here's the people it's okay to talk to
and here's people that we shouldn't be
talking to this is not a an issue of a
hypocritical double standard related to
oh we don't want Trump being friends
with Russia or talking to North Korea
but it would have been okay if Barack
Obama did it you have to understand that
you have to consider the geopolitical
context at the time and you have to
consider the leader Donald Trump is
completely unqualified to do diplomacy
this is not partisanship it's you need
to make sure you have the right person
participating in the talks it's often
mentioned wouldn't it be great to be
friends with Russia and friends with
North Korea or to have the Taliban on
our side or whatever with Barack Obama
it was so is he going to negotiate with
Iran or isn't he and why would it have
been okay for him to do it but not
Donald Trump that is the wrong framework
the correct framework is number one what
is the regime in question that we are
considering negotiating with or meeting
with number two what is the geopolitical
context in which it would take place and
number three who are the people that
would sit down and do it and if it's
Donald Trump with the Taliban at Camp
David
without even cluing in Afghanistan to
the reality that this is going on you've
got it completely in over his head guy
in Donald Trump managing that in the
complete wrong way lending credibility
to the Taliban in a way that circumvents
Afghanistan to our detriment and it's a
bizarre and potentially completely
self-destructive idea Trump with North
Korea without preconditions nothing
happened other than Trump giving away a
propaganda opportunity to Kim jong-un
which Kim jong-un greatly profited from
so to speak
Trump can't even handle a Twitter
disagreement with Chrissy Teigen whose
an actress or a mom I don't even know
what she does a singer she's a model I
don't know what she does but Trump can't
even handle an argument with her how can
we expect Donald Trump to actually make
progress meeting with North Korea or the
Taliban or whoever else so this is not
about double standards where whoever a
Democrat chooses to negotiate with or
have dialogue with as Obama like to say
is fine
but if a Republican tries to do the same
thing it's not okay Trump is clueless
and lacks all sense of decorum and
diplomacy and that's why we need to be
so careful he doesn't even understand
for example with North Korea he
considered it an achievement that he was
able to get a meeting with Kim jong-un
there have been decades multiple North
Korean leaders who have been desperate
to meet with an American president it's
been the American presidents who
recognize that without some
preconditions from the North Korean
leadership these are merely meetings
that serve propaganda purposes for them
so it's anybody who's looking for the
list of who it is and isn't okay to meet
with you have to be thinking bigger and
you have to be thinking in a more
nuanced way Donald Trump is not has not
shown that he's capable of that type of
thinking and he simply lacks the
knowledge to do it as well if you
disagree with me on this let me know